While this engagement ratio certainly tells us something about your engagement,
there are a few flaws as with any operational definition and method of measuring
a construct, in this case the construct of engagement. For example, what if you
logged on and were watching lessons, but then your friend called. And so, you
spent an hour talking to her while the videos continued to play. Or sure, you
can come up with a few flaws in using this as the sole measure in engagement.
So, here's another option. You could self report how engaged you are on a scale
from one to ten. Since engagement doesn't necessarily equal learning, I'll also
ask you how much you feel like you're learning on a scale from one to ten. So,
go ahead and tell me how you'd rank your engagement and learning by clicking the
link below. When you're done, just click Yes. The purpose of this quiz is just
to make sure the video is paused. Giving you enough time to click the link and
rate your engagement and learning.